[Music]
so it is just after 10 o'clock GMT and
we start in the United Kingdom where
former Chancellor Rishi sunak has just
announced that he will run to become the
next prime minister candidates hoping to
lead the governing conservative party
have one more day to gather the support
of at least a hundred members of
parliament former prime minister Boris
Johnson is expected to be sunac's main
challenger but but he has yet to
announce his candidacy officially he met
sunak for talks on Saturday tallies by
British media suggests that tunak has a
sunac has a clear lead in the number of
MPS backing him however Johnson's
backers say that he also has enough to
run senior Cabinet member penny mordant
has also declared that she's running but
it's unclear if she has enough support
to even enter the race
I'm not sharing my canvassing data with
the with the others I am very confident
about the progress we are making and I
will say to you that I'm in this to win
it I think it's important for our party
we have a contest I am very confident
about our numbers and it's I the reason
why I'm doing this is because I think I
am best place to bring the party
together
Stephanie Decker is live for us in
London Stephanie we knew Rishi sunak was
running but now he's made it official
yes it really is all about what is
official or what isn't he as early as
yesterday his Camp had already said they
have the numbers they have over 100
nominations which is what the candidates
need as you mentioned there to run uh
for the post of a leader of the party
and prime minister so just in the last
half hour he tweeted a statement saying
um I'm standing to be the next prime
minister the UK is a great country but
we Face a profound economic crisis and I
want to fix the economy unite our party
and deliver for our country now fixing
the economy is a major task we're
talking about all the ins and outs of
the specifics of the political back and
forth here but this is a country and a
people facing a severe economic crisis
so whoever comes into Downing Street is
going to have to tackle that immediately
now we're going to have to wait and see
what Boris Johnson's next step is these
are two men who have a very turbulent
past
um they had that meeting last night as
you mentioned there was some speculation
perhaps a deal would be struck which
would prevent uh the members of the
conservative party voting for the next
prime minister this is what's going to
happen if you have more than one
candidate they'll be voting and then
we'll know on Friday
um but Boris Johnson this morning uh
coming out to supporters and saying that
he is not backing down that he is the
man for the job and that despite uh the
public tally of those supporting him
which is around 50 I think still at this
point in time he says in his supporters
say that he has those numbers so at this
point it's a waiting game whether he's
gonna throw his hat into the ring today
whether he's going to wait until
tomorrow 2 p.m is that deadline on
Monday until all candidates
um need to say that they have the
numbers anymore that the only one saying
that she's running not clear yet if she
has those numbers Stephanie on that
Boris Johnson Rishi sunac meeting I mean
observers of British political life will
I think will agree with this that it's
not lacking the drama this this very
short race for the leadership what do we
know if anything about that meeting
yes the meeting was behind closed closer
so we have absolutely no information as
to what was discussed I think you know
it is clear as you mentioned there are
these two men are not friends they have
a history Boris Johnson appointed
Richard zunak as Chancellor he was quite
unknown at the time but the bigger
picture in the the the the events that
progressed is that Richard sunak then
was one of the first to call for Boris
Johnson to stand down amid the scandals
that Boris Johnson is still under
investigation for um so Boris Johnson
sees him as having stabbed him in the
back as being the man that perhaps led
to his downfall many others would tell
you that Boris Johnson has managed to
bring those things upon himself having
said all that this gives you a little
bit of context between the animosity
perhaps between uh the two men
um but you know no one is backing down
it seems certainly at this point uh
according to the words of Boris Johnson
he hasn't still officially uh put his um
hat into the ring but I think from what
it looks like for the moment at least it
looks like they the two men could be the
Front Runners uh for this race full of
this back and forth I think when you
talk to the people here if we bring it
back down to what really matters you
have all this political back and forth
with personal issues and agendas and
people wanting to keep their job this is
a party that is hugely fragmented this
is a party at its own neck for years now
and this is also what you're seeing the
question is can this party even govern
um moving forward with the divisions
that there are this is why many people
are also calling for a general election
but this is a party polling at an
all-time low so observers will tell you
that that is not going to be something
that they will be doing uh certainly not
voluntarily but a lot of people a lot of
Brits wanting to be able to have their
own say as to who's going to be running
their country
Stephanie Decker reporting live from
London thank you very much let's take a
look back at Boris Johnson's downfall as
prime minister he was already a divisive
figure when he came to office in 2019
many britons saw him as an opportunist
who used turmoil around brexit to push
out his predecessor but his handling of
the pandemic the following year and the
scandals that emerged hurt his
popularity even among conservative
voters in December last year reports
emerged of several illegal parties at
Johnson's official residence during
covid-19 lockdowns in June he survived a
confidence vote but with just 60 percent
of his MPS backing him but Johnson was
finally forced out the next month after
several senior cabinet members resigned
and that includes Rishi sunak his rival
today all right let's speak to Daniel
kashinski a conservative member of the
UK Parliament he joins us live as it
were from Ulan Batar in Mongolia do you
already know who you're going to back in
this race
um no I don't because my local party in
Shrewsbury is conducting a an online
poll of our members which will be
published at five o'clock this afternoon
London time and it's my intention to
obviously wanting to see the results of
that poll of my local party members
before I make my final decision
will you decide so will you do what the
poll says if they say penny Morton you
back Morton if they say Boris Johnson
you back Johnson
well I think the problem that we have
with this election uh is that it is so
uh polarized uh the characters are
creating so much polarization not only
with party members but with the
electorate themselves uh the characters
the the nature of the the characters of
what's happened over the last few months
it's it's created a very difficult
impassioned and at times tense situation
and therefore I think the best thing for
a member of parliament under those
circumstances is to not only take into
account his or her own feelings and
considerations but also those of them so
I've decided that that the result of
that will ultimately influence the way I
vote Yes okay so let me ask you
differently then what are you looking
for in the next prime minister
foreign
who has dedicated my professional life
to the conservative party I've been a
conservative part Member of Parliament
for 17 years I've never known uh this
sort of ranker and division uh and it is
very destabilizing uh destabilizing for
the party destabilizing for the country
so it's extremely important that we find
somebody uh who can bring the party
together who can try to engage with the
electorate and prepare us for a general
election because you know the labor
party is getting stronger and stronger I
think they're very left-wing in the
United Kingdom and I think they will do
great damage to our economy so our
anniversary is not each other our
adversary is our our political opponents
in the Socialist Party so in that case
um does that rule out Boris Johnson then
because he was persona non grata when he
left uh it why is the conservative party
now considering bringing him back only a
few months later what has he done in the
interim that would change uh the way he
is perceived by the general public and
by conservatives other than go on
holiday it's
it's not what he's done uh it's what's
happened
um subsequently to his removal from
Office uh the media and I put a lot of
the responsibility on this on the
British media that meet we had nothing
for six months uh in the United Kingdom
apart from a media hysteria as to
whether or not the Prime Minister had a
glass of wine or a piece of cake in the
in the garden of number 10 Downing
Street and our country was taken over
for six months by that media height
subsequently as a result of his removal
we've had a new government a new prime
minister a completely new approach which
has actually failed to secure uh what
Mrs trust wanted to secure through the
financial markets and that has caused
even greater problems for for us so we
have a saying here at the United Kingdom
hold on to nurse for fear of worse and
sometimes uh throwing somebody under a
bus did teaching them removing them uh
halfway through a period of office has
very calamities consequences and that's
what we're experiencing at the moment
all right Danielle kevchinski thank you
very much and to your point on media I I
suspect the British media would answer
that they were holding the prime
minister to account uh thank you so much
for your time today on Al Jazeera
thank you